they're not of the same school age but
they're all here forced together by the
sheer lack of alternatives
there's no school for these children
even at the heart of the Malian capital
bamako their families have been
displaced by ethnic fighting and attacks
by local armed groups in the central
region of mopti at least 3 000
individuals are huddled in these cocoons
of stick and straw in the falladia camp
for the displaced in West bamako
a displaced Fulani from the central area
of burkesi is trying to help them
as a quranic teacher I have decided to
do my share the children are living in
really bad conditions the place is so
dirty as you can see so at least I can
give them something that can help them
later in life
Zakaria lost two brothers during the
violence they left behind four widows
and several children in need of care and
education
his neighbor in the camp fatumata on
goiba a dogon is supposed to be his
enemy but the two communities who fought
one another in mopti are sharing the
same camp in bamako peacefully
she also brought her children here
without any guarantees they'll get an
education
she knows that the chances back home are
even Slimmer a quarter of schools in the
central region of moti have remained
closed since 2019.
it's a nationwide crisis especially in
the north where armed groups are
fighting against the central government
schools in Timbuktu are struggling
the historic city is under partial seed
by an Al-Qaeda affiliate
flights to the city have been suspended
and River Transport disrupted the
central government is all but totally
absent we are quite concerned that about
half a million children
will not return to school
that is the overall situation
of the education situation
in Mali currently however
we must recognize that the Ministry of
Education with partners
are doing a lot to make sure that these
children go back to school
the UN is trying to help but that may
become a real challenge especially when
its last peacekeepers will leave Mali by
the end of December that's only three
months from now and if no solid
protection measures are put in place
ahead of that date the state of
education and of Peace itself in this
country may go from bad to worse
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera